welcome back finley toyota the sponsor
of this next segment has a top-notch
service department john barr had us come
down to take a look at the service area
in one very special vehicle
[Music]
hey john how's it going i'm doing great
i had to get you down there jc i've got
a surprise here i know you're a huge
back to the future fan oh i've got
something special here what do you got
behind you a delorean no something even
better
it's the toyota from back to the future
this is marty mcfly's toyota sr5 from
the movie john this is incredible i knew
you'd love it you know the secret to
having a vehicle like this is surface
yeah exactly that's true yeah it's the
only way to kind of keep it up because
obviously 35 36 years old but i got the
guy to help you douglas come over and
meet jc hey doug
see you buddy good to see you man all
right let's show me around the service
department doug the first thing i
noticed walking back here is the size
how big is the facility yeah we're one
of the largest dealerships in the
country so we have a hundred service
stalls and about 70 technicians now
what's this guy what's your technician
chris working on here uh looks today
like he's actually just doing some basic
maintenance we're replacing spark plugs
today and that's what you do here right
it doesn't matter the make or model you
service all vehicles yeah we'll work on
all makes and models um even though
we're a toyota dealership but we'll do
anything from your basic you know
maintenance the tire replacement all the
way up to an engine replacement looks
like someone's here was working on some
tires changing out some tires here yeah
we're probably just doing a tire
rotation on this one that's perfect
that's great now you do you service all
vehicles and how many technicians do you
have working back here we have 70
technicians 70 technicians 75 if you
need your car service there's gonna be
someone here at finley toyota that's
gonna take care of it yeah we welcome
walk-ins um obviously you can schedule
an appointment but we're staffed enough
to where we can take you in any time
that you want to come in i noticed that
these are all over the shop what does
this say you got a chain here what's
this thing up here uh this is actually
an exhaust fan so uh basically when the
technicians are working on the cars and
they're running in their bay they hook
them to the exhaust so we can keep the
air in here clean connected oh my gosh
you take care of your people i i love
that now if someone does get their
vehicle serviced do you offer rental
programs um so we have we give
complimentary lift rides to and from if
we need to we do have a rental
department here if somebody wants to
rent a car we can do that and we also
offer a pickup and delivery service also
if people don't have the time to make it
down we saw this is an older toyota here
we have the back to the future truck how
important is it to stay on top of
service of your vehicle yeah i mean if
you want the car to run a long time
maintenance is the key so um as long as
you can keep up on the maintenance as
you can see in the shop we have a lot of
cars that that have quite a bit of age
on them but they're still running and
that's because people you know do the
maintenance that they need they see on
top of things you're certified free on
vehicles how many checks do they go
through back there before we put them on
the lot so every certified toyota that
we have goes through 160 point
inspection
wow you see you look look over
everything what do we got here doing
some brake work back here yeah it looks
like that's more uh replacing the rear
brakes
brake's right here thanks for right here
i know my stuff thank you i appreciate
it buddy appreciate you man thank you
very much all right john i'm ready for
my test drive what road are we taking
roads
where we're going we don't need roads
[Music]
thank you to findlay toyota for
sponsoring this segment they're located
in henderson and you can call them at
nine 702-566-2596 or find them online at
findlaytoyota.com